today we are joined by christopher burke
a local personal injury attorney he is
the owner of the patriot law firm and if
you were
hurt by a jerk you better call burke
that's the slogan chris how are things
in the personal injury world right now
hey rocky great to be back uh you know
the patriot law firm is moving forward
ever onward ever upward
uh we're so happy we get a chance to
represent las vegas valley residents
every single day today we are discussing
a case you recently had against a local
nursing home
related to neglect and abuse right
that's right rocky recently i was able
to negotiate
a six-figure settlement for a family
that had a one of their senior members
in
a local nursing home here in las vegas
and it was related to some abuse
neglect unfortunately it was really
related to some bedsores
bed sores that sounds awful what
happened next
well rocky it was awful in this case it
involved a senior citizen that was
admitted to a nursing home that had
mobility issues
now when a senior that has mobility
issues is is admitted to a
nursing care or assisted care living
facility certain precautions need to be
done
they have to make sure that the staff
there may have to make sure that they're
positioning
repositioning the the seniors so that
there's not too much pressure on one
side of them so ultimately
this poor senior citizen suffered some
pretty awful stage
four bed sores or pressure ulcers
unbelievable and
were you able to actually help this
family ultimately yes we were and and
fortunately the family actually retained
me
uh within a week or so of finding out
about the bedsore
when that happens we sprang into action
my firm was able to facilitate a
uh and communicate with the facility
about getting the senior transfer to
another facility to get the proper care
that's great i'm happy our community has
an attorney like you to help our seniors
with these types of cases thank you
chris
helping out our local las vegas senior
citizens are some of the most gratifying
that i work on and i'm happy to do so
give christopher burke a call at the
patriot law firm that number is 702
702-620-2020 or visit their website
at fightforthelittleguy.com